during her 2 months as work in pension
secretary amber Rudd says speaking to
work coaches and claimants in job
centers has left her in no doubt about
what she needs to do do you find
yourself having to reassure people about
the regime so they don't live in fear of
it the whole idea is to get yourself for
them ready for the future rather than
just for now on benefits aiming to build
confidence in the controversial welfare
reform she's preparing to press the
reset button on universal credit I am
looking at ways to demonstrate to people
that it is fair and compassionate and
with that in mind I am making some
changes but overall my aim to do this
reset is effectively to build confidence
in universal credit as well as steps to
make weekly and fortnightly payments
more accessible and a new online system
for private landlords she will also
scrap the planned extension to the to
Child Benefit cap the policy which was
due to come into effect next month would
have applied retrospectively to children
born before the policy was introduced I
don't think it's right that you have
this existing to child policy which was
introduced recently acting
retrospectively for people who might
have to have children well I'm not gonna
comment on why came in and why it was
proposed in the past it doesn't that say
something about the the philosophy
behind universal credit which so many
people are critical of well I would add
accrual this the total City no I totally
reject that and on the four-year
benefits freeze and indication it will
not be renewed when it ends in a year's
time it was the right policy at the time
it's got one more year to run I look
forward to it coming off so you think it
will come to an end has one more year to
run and then it will come to the end and
I do not expect that to be renewed at
all no but for all her current focus on
universal credit for many the true
significance of her return to cabinet is
her potential influence when it comes to
brexit the government has suffered two
parliamentary defeats this week at the
hands of pro-european Tory rebels a
group with whom and the Rudd has much in
common if you were not in cabinet would
you be voting alongside them do you
think oh it's very difficult to tell
because I'm in cabinet I'm committed to
the government policy on brexit getting
it right is so important for everything
that I'm doing in my
Department and everything the
government's doing to try and improve
the economy and work with families the
worst outcome would be a No Deal brexit
where the economy would be adversely
impacted that's not quite an endorsement
of rebellion but by linking the future
of universal credit to avoiding a No
Deal brexit and the Rudd is perhaps
offering the reminder of where her
ultimate sympathies lie
Tom Rayner Sky News Westminster